good morning to you
Oh this morning the college met to
discuss the situation stemming from the
tensions in Iraq Iran the wider Middle
East and as well as Libya and while
we're standing here we're still
following the developments I would like
to express my deepest condolences to all
who lost their beloved ones in the crash
of the Ukrainian aircrafts this morning
at this moment it is for the aviation
security experts to investigate the
cause of the crash providing answers to
this horrible tragedy with the current
crisis deeply affects not only the
region but all of us and the use of
weapons must stop now to give space to
dialogue we all are called upon to do
everything possible to rekindle talks
and there cannot be enough of that the
European Union in its own way has a lot
to offer we have established and
time-tested relations with many actors
in the region and beyond to de-escalate
the situation
I asked High Representative and the
Commission vice president Joseph Karev
today in college to debrief on the
developments and on his contacts as well
as actions undertaken so far he will
provide you with more details in the
medium-term as coordinator of jcpoa
Joseph Burrell you will spare no efforts
to reach out to all participants to
safeguard the Iranian nuclear deal and
moreover the college also analyzed
potential consequences of the current
crisis on the European Union for example
in areas of transport and energy on
neighborhood and migration but also the
economic development the stabilization
and the reconstruction the European
Union is doing in this area European
Union is dedicated there and very much
engaged in this area and therefore its
voice is heard
we've looked comprehensively at the
internal and external dimension of this
issue to ensure that we act as
effectively as possible as you know I'm
now on my way to London I shall meet
Prime Minister Boris Johnson this
afternoon and of course the situation in
Iran and the Iraq will also be a topic
it is in our mutual interest to build a
new partnership between the European
Union and the United Kingdom one that
will be enabling us to defend and
strengthen our interest both from an
economic and security point of view and
I would like to hand over the floor now
to the a thank you very much madam
president allow me to start by joining
my condolences to the families of the
victims of the tragic crash of the
Ukrainian plane two night in Iran now on
the topic of this morning meeting I want
to stress that the recent developments
in Iran and attack on the whole region
are extremely worrying and we have had a
very fruitful discussion at the college
but what the Commission can do one thing
is clear the current situation puts at
risk the efforts of the past years and
also has implications for the important
work of the anti-daesh coalition the
last rocket attack on air bases in Iraq
used by US and the coalition forces
among them European forces
are yet another example of ex collation
and increased confrontation it is on no
one interest to turn up the spiral of
violence even further at an immediate
next step I have convened an
extraordinary meeting with the Foreign
Affairs Council
what is Friday you have to leave Croatia
first with the 28th still 28 member
state and we will discuss what European
Union can do in the short of the medium
and long term to help to stabilize the
region we have been talking with the
colleagues also on the situation as you
said Madam President of the GC POA which
is today more important than ever the
process the only place where we can see
together with the Russians and she means
to talk on a multilateral basis about
many risk that we are facing is one of
the most important role of the
non-proliferation and regional security
I invited foreign affairs minister of
Iran by Brussels maybe we'll have a
meeting soon in order to together
analyze the situation of this agreement
in which European Union has put a lot of
effort in order to maintain it after the
withdrawal of the United States I am in
touch with our participants as
coordinator to keep the unity of the
group of the European countries
represented in the world of the living
and they imported the full
implementation by all parties I want
also to stress the strong support to the
Berlin process is the tool we have in
hands in order to face the situation in
Libya and not jumping from one crisis to
another maybe is closer to us
it doesn't take risk of a nuclear
proliferation of confrontation but there
we are may be facing a watershed point
situation is very dangerous
yesterday II had planned to go to Libya
together with the four ministers of the
for European countries Germany France
Italy United Kingdom finally it was not
possible due to the risky situation
there instead we had a meeting in
Brussels and we are waiting for the
visit of the prime minister of Libya mr.
surage and we will also meet here in
Rome mr. Guido nowhere with other Libyan
leaders in order to analyze with them
the situation will talk about it and the
next foreign affairs consume and thank
you very much madam president for having
the opportunity talking together with my
our colleagues and the Commission
college about the situation in which
European Union and especially to the
peel Commission had a lot to do for an
example we have and partnership and
cooperation agreement with Iraq a very
recent one it was signed a one-year and
I have a go and it's opened the door to
ongoing programs on the multi annual
financial aid work and so about the
national framework and they have many
many frogs with many issues we can make
a contribution in order to ensure the
stabilization of the region